If you’d wanted to know what the future looked like before it arrived, all you
really had to do was look at the Jetsons.
(Music) “Meet George Jetson.”
The television series described many things we now see in the 21st century
long before we’d even finished the 20th. The Jetsons predicted our present
technology and lifestyle. So, since they were so great at telling us what
today would look like what can this cartoon family teach us about future tech and
how automation will alter our lives?
“You think. You think! Your machine is supposed to do the thinking, Jetson.”
“I have feelings, like everyone else.”
“The future is happening now. And the question is: When will it be distributed so everyone benefits from it?”
Hey, everyone. I’m Joel. This is AJ+. And this Sunday we’re looking into a colorful cartoon past
to better understand our automated future.
And yes, we will talk about robots, jobs – and the dark side of automation.
Flying cars. Moving walkways. Video conferencing. Computers. And robotic
maids. Those are all things the Jetsons had. When George, Jane, Judy and Elroy
premiered on ABC in 1962, all those things were unimaginable as part of a daily life.
Future tech was color TV when the Jetsons began, because it wasn’t
wasn’t until the 1960s when color televisions began selling en masse. So the thought that
Rosie, the family’s robotic maid, would one day become a part of daily
daily life as an automatic vacuum cleaner may have been inconceivable then. But in 2018,
Rosie looks like this, and sounds like this.
“You have 12 events scheduled.” The world is rushing to automate.
Think grocery
store checkouts, self-driving cars and how shipping has evolved. In fact the
the automated household of the Jetsons is only a decade away, according to tech entrepreneur
Vivek Wadhwa. “When I was young, it was my favorite TV series. I
expect to have a robot like Rosie cleaning up after me. Rather than having
servants and maids and chauffeurs, we'll have robots serving us.”
So maybe your morning routine doesn’t look exactly like George Jetson’s – yet! But
it already has some similarities. And unlike the Jetsons’ total embrace of the
technology around them, society in real life has been hesitant about some
technological advances. The trepidation may have something to do with hearing
forecasts like this from World Bank President Jim Yong Kim. “We estimate that
two-thirds of all jobs in developing economies will be
wiped out by automation.” Take a second to think of any and every job that makes up our economy.
Well, 50% of those work activities are
technically able to be automated by current technologies. Even the Obama White House has
has said almost every driving job – that’s your taxi driver, the delivery
driver who delivers the food to your local grocery store and the
long-haul truckers you see on the interstate – all of their jobs will be
be automated. “That’s f*cked up, yo! What the f*ck are they going to do if they
make everything autonomous?” Maybe hearing those statistics makes you want to panic.
But AI and robotics expert Neil Jacobstein says you don’t have to and
and shouldn’t get hysterical about the worst that can happen with automation. “If you
run your risk assessment by what's the worst that can happen, you would run a
a risk assessment around many of the technologies that are already in the
world today and can conclude that they should all be banned, including cars.”
Jacobstein says we haven’t banned vehicles just because they have the potential to
run down pedestrians. That’s a worst-case scenario. And he says that if we’d used it to
determine the future of cars, we would never have had them. So we have cars, and
actually, we have much more than you may realize.
Wadhwa says it’s important to recognize just how far automation and AI have
already come. “We have to understand the technology advances and accept the fact
fact that this is going to happen. Don't be in denial about it. Understand the fact that
every industry is going to be impacted.” And when he says AI and automation will
impact every single industry, he means it. It’s not just jobs
reliant upon physical labor that are at risk.
Those are things you’ve probably already heard and thought about – like the truck
driver example we talked about earlier. You can also expect careers that require
a lot of intelligence to be disrupted, and here’s why.  “Because what artificial intelligence does,
it analyzes data, information, and makes decisions.” “We're
going to see them augment humans in human roles. So there'll be machines plus humans
outperforming either humans or machines alone.” Whoa! Maybe this is why– in
a world filled with advanced technology – George Jetson’s only job is to push a
couple of buttons. “After all, I’m a darn good digital index operator.
You gotta have it up here to know how to start these things and stop ’em.”
And according to Mr. Spacely, he didn’t even do that well.  [steam engine sound] “You dunderhead! You dolt!”
This means even George’s cushy job could be disrupted, too. “You’re fired!” I don't think that there is any limit to
what the systems can learn to do, eventually.”  Jacobstein says automation’s benefits won’t
come without turmoil – AKA serious growing pains. “The question is not whether AI and
robotics will create new jobs, because it's absolutely true that they will
create and do create new jobs the the
question is what's the ratio of new jobs. The question is: What's the
the ratio of new job creation to job displacement or destruction? And I think that ratio
could easily be unfavorable, at least in the short term.” To understand what this could
mean, let’s look at the medical industry.
There are already digital doctors
that can look at your health, and digital tutors that can teach you. Wadhwa says
the ability to diagnose yourself and have AI advise you on maintaining your health
isn’t far away. In fact, Wadhwa says there we will be fewer doctors because of
this – and it may affect some of the most specialized positions first. If you’re
questioning what other jobs will be available in the automated age,
realize we may already be doing them and just not getting compensated.
“In the long term, we could create new jobs that are jobs we don't see today
or people don't get paid to do today. A lot of work that people do in volunteer
work could be paid. We are already doing many jobs in today's world that people
people would never call a job 200 years ago.” To prepare for this future,
Wadhwa says the best way to deal with automation’s disruption is to look at the past.
“Alright, take a deep breath.” [inhales] “Now exhale.” [exhales]
OK, but not that far in the past.
And in my interview, Wadhwa told me that
the case study to look at is the Great Depression. The crippling economic
downturn left about a quarter of the workforce jobless at one point.
The federal government’s response is what’s known as the New Deal. It included public
works projects and financial reforms, all aimed at getting people back to work.
So, much like the Great Depression, the disruption automation and AI
gives us a chance to reboot our lives. “We can rethink our society, rethink our
rethink our entire value system, and go back to what matters. This is the opportunity we
have now. All in the next 10, 15, 20 years.” While we’re thinking of all the changes
needed in the United States to deal with the result of automation, just know it’s
not a one-size-fits-all solution. What’s required in Nigeria, Australia or India
isn’t the same as the U.S. "Countries such as India and Bangladesh and Pakistan,
for example, there's infrastructure to be built. We can put all those people
to work in building new cities. Abandon the existing cities, which are polluted."
But there is one thing all nations will have to troubleshoot.
“We really need to think ahead about what we're going to do to help people
maintain a high quality of lifestyle and be able to move forward with their lives. If we're going to rely on jobs
being the primary mechanism of wealth distribution, then we might easily see
see businesses cutting jobs and replacing those jobs with automation –
– both AI and robotics – and people losing jobs.” So yes, automation and AI will bring a lot of changes, a lot of which
which will be very uncomfortable. But does that mean it will all be bad for humanity? “It's not
all hopeless. You know, who says we have to work 40, 50, 60 hours a week? Why
are jobs so important? What if we only had to work 5 or 10 hours a week?
What if everyone now had everything they needed and the purpose of life, the goals
that we had, were to seek enlightenment?”
Hey, thanks for watching. Be sure to like, share and subscribe. And I just produced a three-part series
on this topic: AI, automation and robotics. So be sure to check that out.